rich people do not value money the way  poor people do they they they invest  money they don't spend it  you know the best the best spending is  still worse than the best and the the  worst investment  like you could make a bad investment  that would still be better than a smart  spend when you spend money you don't get  an investment back  and when you invest money at least you  got a possibility i mean the very at the  very least you get a tax write-off  so if i spend money on a belt  i can't write it off i can only wear it  and if i invest money in a grant cardone  belt  and wear it on stage and it flops as a  product and nobody ever buys it  it's at least a write-off it was at  least a promotion so a bad investment is  still better than a smart spin so  wealthy people don't spend money they  invest money